with five columns right off the bat we
know that we can't do four columns
evenly so this can't be right with eight
columns it's impossible to have three
evenly spaced columns so we know that
eight columns isn't right with twelve
columns we know that two three and four
all divide into 12 evenly meaning that
we can have to even columns three even
columns or four even columns on the
screen so this seems like a pretty good
answer but let's think about 20 with 20
columns 3 doesn't divide into 20 evenly
so we know that we can't do 3 even
columns on the screen also you'll notice
that people need to be able to read
things and if a column is 120th of the
screen it's going to be pretty tiny and
that's going to be hard to see so I
can't imagine us ever needing a column
that small this means that the correct
answer is 12 columns and in fact most of
the grid systems if not all of the grid
systems that you'll see today
use 12 columns